welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Stewart Schwartz the George Burton
Adams professor of history at Yale
University professor Schwartz
specializes in the history of colonial
Latin America especially Brazil and on
the history of early modern expansion
among his books our sovereignty and
society in colonial Brazil early Latin
America sugar plantations in the
formation of Brazilian society slaves
peasants and rebels Cambridge history of
native peoples of the Americas and South
America he is presently working on
several projects a history of
independence of Portugal and the crisis
of Iberian Atlantic 1622 1670 and a
social history of Caribbean hurricanes
today however we'll speak with him about
his newest groundbreaking book all can
be saved religious tolerance and
salvation in the iberian atlantic world
so let's begin with an overview of your
book and the premise well this is a book
about the history of tolerance not
toleration the way it's usually
understood by which people usually mean
state policy regarding religious freedom
but tolerance the attitude of people
towards the religion of others of their
neighbors and in that history usually
Spain and the Spanish world is left out
because it enters in only as an example
of intolerance the age of the
Inquisition
the suppression of religious freedom so
the book is somewhat distinct in that it
emphasizes Spain
and the origins of religious tolerance
in Spain and the spanish-speaking world
ok and what was your inspiration for
writing the book the inspiration came
one cold winter evening when I was
living in Minneapolis
I was reading a book by an Italian
scholar Carlo Ginsburg called the cheese
and the worms it's about the the
worldview of a very common man a Miller
and when he was being questioned by the
inquisitors he said to them well of
course he was a Catholic but if he had
been brought up in amongst the Turks he
would have thought their religion was
the right religion and he would have
found his salvation because after all
God loves us all and I thought at the
time gee that's a curious thing to say
for a man in the sixteenth century where
do they get those ideas
doesn't that sound quite unlike what
people ought to be thinking in the
sixteenth century I shut off the light
and went to sleep and forgot all about
it 20 years later I was working in the
Spanish archives and began to find
indications of other people who thought
the exactly the same thing and it struck
me as very curious how could that be
possible in the age of the Inquisition
that people would develop that kind of
idea of toleration and the idea that
salvation was possible in many religions
and that was the origins of the book
okay let's talk about your methodology a
bit you drew on an enormous body of
historical evidence to write your book
tell us a little bit about the process
and did you encounter any difficulties
well the Inquisition was a great
bureaucratic institution and it was
particularly interested in what people
not only what people did but what they
said what they thought and so it took
very very careful records and while not
all of those records have survived many
of them have for the Portuguese
Inquisition we have over 40,000 cases
Wow for the Spanish Inquisition also
about 40,000 and so it's possible to
reconstruct these these cases and these
are some of the few instances when
common people were recorded what they
actually thought so rather than being a
study of intellectuals it's possible to
do it a study of common people
that's the great advantage that the
Inquisition gives us it's sort of a
almost a kind of contradiction that we
owe so much to the life of and to the
ideas of common people that through this
basically ecclesiastical institution but
that's really the result of of this
investigation okay and your work really
differs from much of the existing work
for this period talk about that a little
bit well the way that toleration
religious toleration is usually
explained or thought of is in the terms
of great ideas
there's Erasmus or Spinoza or Rousseau
or John Locke and they write a kind of
breakthrough Brook or essay and then
somehow that catches on and lo and
behold you get to the modern world and
religious toleration becomes accepted
but the traditional way to look at that
is never to pay much attention at the
reception of these ideas how did the
idea get from Locke's essay on religious
tolerance how did it get to become a
general accepted idea no one ever pays
much attention to that so what makes my
book different is that it's interested
in the common people their ideas their
reception and the interaction of their
ideas would these great thinkers in fact
the book goes beyond that to suggest
that perhaps some of these ideas don't
come from the great thinkers down to the
people but in fact go the other way
around that these ideas are already
around and it's the great thinkers
synthesize them and integrate them into
an argument even though these ideas
aren't necessarily generated by them so
it's an inversion of the way in which we
usually think of intellectual change in
and what conclusions do you reach in
your book well the conclusion is that
one might argue that Spain had a
peculiar history because in the Middle
Ages there were Muslims and Jews and
Christians who lived together in Spain
and even though they didn't always get
along together nevertheless there was a
certain everyday interchange and they
understood each other at least even
though they might not always like each
other and when the Spanish go to the new
world they encounter Indians and then
later bring in Africans and so there was
already a kind of predisposition to
accept other cultures other ways of
thinking but one of the conclusions of
the book is that this this isn't a
peculiarly Spanish phenomenon and then
if you scratch deep enough in England or
Italy or France or Germany that you'll
find the same ideas it's just that the
way in which we've written the history
of the early modern world has basically
basically been in terms of the struggle
of religion so nobody's looked much for
cooperation or tolerance they've always
been interested in what drove people
apart not what drew them together but if
you scratch the surface a little bit you
can find lots of examples in Italy or
England or or in France and so in that
sense the book even though it's about
Spain and in and port Spain Portugal and
the Iberian Atlantic world that is the
Americas it concludes that in fact this
is a more general European phenomenon
and that we really need need to rethink
the whole idea of how toleration was
born and became an aspect of the modern
world fascinating and last question what
was one of the most surprising things
you found in doing your research well I
think the willingness of people to
contest Authority very simple people
people with hardly any education we're
at some point came to a personal
conviction that the church was wrong
on this issue the church's position we
have to remember was there is no
salvation outside the church you had to
be a member of the church in order to be
saved but common people with their own
sort of common sense couldn't quite get
it they didn't understand how could an
all merciful God condemn so many people
to eternal damnation it didn't make
sense to them and so they sometimes even
try to convince the inquisitors that the
inquisitors are wrong what's the most
curious about this is that these people
were willing to stand up against the
authority of the state and the authority
of the church in order to make this
argument they had no personal gain in
this it wasn't that it was good for
business
because by this time there were no Jews
in in Spain there were no Muslims left
in Spain so there was no direct economic
or personal benefit but these people
became convinced out of their belief
some of them were skeptics some of them
were atheist but some of them thought of
themselves as good Catholics and simply
thought on this particular issue that
the church had got it wrong in some way
these people are closer to the position
of the Roman Catholic Church after
vatican ii in the 20th century then the
inquisitors were the questions that were
trying to correct them were to vatican
ii and so the most interesting thing I
think in is that we have to listen to
the voice of these common people and the
fact that they're uneducated doesn't
mean that they don't have a common sense
understanding of the world and a desire
to live in a better world a world that
they could foresee one in which it
didn't matter so much what church their
neighbor went to so long as it was a
good neighbor very good thank you so
much for being here with us today and
sharing some of your work it's been a
pleasure for more information about
professor Schwartz and his work please
visit our website at yale.edu backslash
Macmillan report be sure to join us
again
another episode of the Macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Centre for
International and area studies at Yale